first of all I think the biggest
misconception about overweight and
obesity is that it's the patient's fault
this is truly a disease now you're right
like we said before you could eat less
but that's like telling somebody who has
diabetes to control their sugar by just
not taking in sugar and of course we
tell them to do it it's very hard to do
your body is mismanaging these things
and so obesity is a disease it is not
the individuals fault it takes
superhuman willpower to keep obesity
under control for the long term and
that's why these surgeries make sense
that these are very dangerous operations
I think 20 years ago the mortality rate
of these operations were in excess of
two percent so of every hundred people
that came in the operating room to
didn't leave the hospital anyway that's
not the case anymore in a center of
excellence in a place that does this
really well and a lot of it the
mortality rate for a gastric bypass is
about three and a thousand and the
mortality rate for a lap band is less
than one in a thousand so these
operations are much safer than they used
to be so much so that the risk
associated with having the operation is
way less than the risk of death from
that operation over the ensuing years
sorry so much so that the risk of having
the operation is way less than the risk
of having obesity for the ensuing years
and you gain back not only the dollars
put into it but the risk put into it
over five years or so the other sorry
common misconception is that they always
fail and people regain their weight back
some of the older operations didn't work
that well and some percentage of
patients do gain way back still but most
don't with gastric bypass I'd say
eighty-five percent of patients maintain
long-term significant weight loss and
with lap band is probably close to the
same just not as dramatically
well that's tough I think that that I
hate to be specific about any
institution I think there's centers of
excellence there's two organizations
that are documenting centers of
excellence in weight loss surgery that's
the American College of Surgeons and
something called the surgical review
corporation a center that is documented
as a center of excellence by those at
least has more than the basics that they
need to do this a center that has one of
these designations probably has
long-term follow-up so that's really
important and the surgeons probably have
at least a minimum amount of experience
doing this so that's important but truly
you want somebody who's done five
hundred or a thousand of these
operations the learning curve goes on
probably to about 250 operations and
then some you want somebody who's
offering you all types of operations not
somebody who's selling just one type or
if somebody does 99% one type of
operation because they're probably
trying to fit you into their operation
not find the best operation for you and
you want some place that has a program
for long-term care and management and if
you have all those three components
you're probably in a place that's safe
well I think the most important thing to
know is that right now less than two
percent of people who qualify for
surgery or having it in most places
that's because patients really aren't
choosing it I think there's
misconceptions about the risk and the
benefits of this operation these
operations save lives they make people
have better quality of life they make
people healthier they make people live
longer but there is some upfront risk
and you need to be at a center of
excellence as we talked about a place
that does this really well to minimize
that risk and overall the benefit is
definitely there for almost everyone who
qualifies for this operation and is
appropriately evaluated so I think
that's really really important the other
important thing to know is that a lot of
states not New York fortunately but a
lot of states the insurance companies
don't really allow patients to have
these operations that patients either
have to fight they get denied they're
excluded from this and I think that's
really important I think Public Health
Paul
see needs to be such that when things
are medically necessary when met things
are medically valuable they aren't
denied patients and this is one area I
think obesity in general is one area of
sort of allowable discrimination because
the public perception is still that
obesity is the patient's fault and if
it's the patient's fault we don't have
to pay money to give them an operation
that isn't going to work anyway in their
minds and that's sort of that the
concept here you wouldn't hold back
open-heart surgery from somebody who has
heart disease because they don't eat a
low-fat diet and smoke you have the
operation you educate them about proper
diet and smoking same thing here you
wouldn't hold back a lung cancer
operation from someone who has a history
of smoking we don't hold back liver
transplants from someone with a history
of drinking why we recognize these
diseases with mortality associated with
them and obesity is the same even more
so you don't need to smoke to live you
don't need to drink to live but you need
to eat to live so you can go cold turkey
off those other things you can't go cold
turkey off food and really then it
becomes a problem of regulation of
amount which is much harder than just
stopping it can't stop eating therefore
the disease is about regulation of the
amount that you eat and that's what's
much about it
well um so how can people finance
surgery is two things number one you can
find an insurance company that does
cover it sometimes that's a possibility
certain states almost everybody comes in
New York it's almost mandated you're
right that obesity does
disproportionately a bit effect the
lower socioeconomic status it's unclear
exactly why perhaps fast food things
like that is more prevalent there's
financing available through some
institutions for this so you can put it
on a payment plan if you will but again
loads of lower socioeconomic status
folks people who you know a relatively
poor might not be able to afford a
20,000 or fifteen thousand dollar
operation even paid off over time I tell
people who can somehow squeeze it
together you'll put a car on financing
even though you otherwise might be able
to take mass transit because you want a
car fifteen twenty thousand dollar
operation is affordable on financing if
you recognize this is for your quality
and length of life may be more important
than having a car in some way so I'm not
telling people they should run out and
pay for these operations if there's
other alternatives certainly getting
insurance to cover it medicare covers
asset centers of excellence Medicaid in
New York covers it but not in all states
and I think working to get legislation
in those areas working to make sure in
the states that this isn't routine
recovered make sure that it is routinely
coverage is in the 40
you